the World Wide Web where you're likely
watching this video is used by millions
of people every day for everything from
checking the weather ordering food and
chatting with friends to raising funds
sharing news or starting revolutions we
use it from our computers our phones
even our cars it's just there all around
us all the time but what is it exactly
well first of all the world wide web is
not the Internet even though the terms
are often used interchangeably the
Internet is simply the way computers
connect to each other in order to share
information when the internet first
emerged computers actually made direct
calls to each other today networks are
all around us so computers can
communicate seamlessly the communication
enabled through the Internet has many
uses such as email file transfer and
conferencing but the most common use is
accessing the world wide web think of
the web as a bunch of skyscrapers each
representing a web server a computer
always connected to the internet
specifically designed to store
information and share it when someone
starts a website they are renting a room
in this skyscraper filling it with
information and linking that information
together in an organized way for others
to access the people who own these
skyscrapers and rent space in them are
called web hosts but anyone can set up a
web server with the right equipment and
a bit of know-how there is another part
to having a web site without which we
would be lost in the city with no way of
finding what we need this is the website
address which consists of domain names
just like with a real-life address a
website address lets you get where you
want to go the information stored in the
web sites is in web languages such as
HTML and JavaScript when we find the web
site we're looking for our web browser
is able to take all the code on the site
and turn it into words graphics and
videos we don't need to know any special
computer languages because the web
browser creates a graphic interface for
us so in a lot of ways the world wide
web is a big virtual city where we
communicate with each other in web
languages with browsers acting as our
translators and just like no one owns a
city no one owns the web it belongs to
all of us anyone can move in and set up
shop we
might have to pay an Internet service
provider to gain access a hosting
company to rent web space or registrar
to reserve our web address
like utility companies in a city these
companies provide crucial services but
in the end not even they own the web but
what really makes the web so special
lies in its very name prior to the web
we used to consume most information in a
linear fashion in a book or newspaper
article each sentence was read from
beginning to end page by page in a
straight line until you reached the end
but that isn't how our brains actually
work each of our thoughts is linked to
other thoughts memories and emotions in
a loose interconnected Network like a
web Tim berners-lee the father of the
World Wide Web understood that we needed
a way to organize information that
mirrored this natural arrangement and
the web accomplishes this through
hyperlinks by linking several pages
within a website or even redirecting you
to other websites to expand on
information or ideas immediately as you
encounter them hyperlinks allow the web
to operate along the same lines as our
thought patterns the web is so much a
part of our lives because in content and
structure it reflects both the wider
society and our individual minds and it
connects those minds across all
boundaries not only ethnicity gender and
age but even time and space
Oh